auf seiner brust steht razzia dabei
handelt es sich nicht um einen
schreibfehler sondern um den vornamen
seiner frau und dennoch wirkt es als
wenn er was geahnt hätte denn heute
morgen um 6 uhr klopfte die polizei
damme an seiner tür zur razzia der
32-jährige spanien er lag da noch im
bett als gsg 9 und anti terror einheit b
f e plus hereinstürmten und ihn
festnahmen
er soll kopf einer bande in lüneburg
sein die sich in der korona krise auf
automaten sprengungen spezialisiert hat
zeitgleich hat die polizei zwei
komplizen festgenommen
alle drei kamen in untersuchungshaft bei
den insgesamt neun durchsuchungen in
lüneburg und umgebung wurden diverse
beweismittel sichergestellt darunter
eine schreckschusswaffe
ein vermutlich gestohlene tresor
einbruchswerkzeuge und mutmaßliches
diebesgut 230 beamte waren im einsatz